we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p and for all
the talk this week about video games as
where we should be looking to understand
the causes of mass shooting something
that has been widely debunked
academically and which i have resisted
all week and and resisted it with fact i
got a very interesting voicemail which
says you know it's one thing to just say
video games are causing violence but did
the shooters play video games because we
haven't heard a thing about that take a
listen to this voicemail very astutely
making this point hey david appreciate
the work you're doing curious why
nobody's asking about their gamer
history if you know they're always the
talking point is that these guys are all
on video games stuff and this is a thing
you know convincing them to kill people
i never see on any news outlets the
questioning asked about their gaming
history
obviously they simply bring this point
up when it's a younger person in most of
these mass shootings aren't committed by
young people all the time but yet nobody
ever asked these things are logged the
xbox is the Playstations they're ours
are logged and especially they're
playing live against other people
there's a record of all that and so i'm
curious why nobody ever asked to see
your gaming history or the police have
ever even looked into it appreciate it
[Music]
this is why i love hearing from the
audience this is why we have the
voicemail number two one nine two david
p i'm in this stuff all day and
sometimes very obvious things just go
over my head because I'm sort of into
deep I lose perspective of some of the
basic questions when Trump talks about
video games in the context of the
shooting when the Texas lieutenant
governor talks about video games in the
context of the shooting when whoever is
talking about video games do we know if
any of these shooters even played video
games it wouldn't even make it a causal
relationship but what are we even
talking about unless they actually
played video games and so far we've
heard nothing about it now to be clear
even if they did it would be merely a
core a core a correlation a
relative relationship correlated
relationship what word am I looking for
here it would not actually prove
causation but it would at least give us
something to start with did any of these
people even play video games what what
how much were they playing what games
were they playing unless we can actually
defend these allegations about video
games they're quite frankly
irresponsible to even be making really
great of voicemail very much appreciate
it leave yours at two one nine to david
p on today's bonus show we will talk
about who Joaquin Castro doubling down
after he tweeted the names of Trump
donors in San Antonio of course that is
public information donor information is
public a man has been charged with
assaulting a 13 year old because the 13
year old didn't remove their hat during
the national anthem
very bizarre story and also we will talk
about the possible connection between
vaccines and sorting out the problems
with cow emissions that impact the
climate of planet Earth all of those
stories and more on today's bonus show
two ways to get access to the bonus show
number one become a member at david
pakman.com slash membership number two
become a patron at patreon.com slash
david pakman show I'll speak to you then